A miser sold everything he owned and bought some gold with the money he got.
"This gold will never get old," he thought.
"And it cannot break, so I can always sell it when I need money."
"However, gold is easy to steal, so I will bury it."
That same night, he went into a field and buried the gold.
From time to time, he went to the field and would dig up the gold...
...to make sure it was still there,...
...then he would bury it again.
A man who was building a house nearby saw the miser burying the gold again.
One night, the man went into the miser's field,...
...dug up the bar of gold, and stole it.
The miser went to the hole the next day. He could not find the gold.
He was very unhappy!
A friend saw him crying and asked what the matter was.
When the miser told him, the friend said,...
..."Put some stones in the hole and pretend they are gold."
"You didn't use the gold when you had it,...
...so it doesn't matter that there will only be stones in the hole."